- [Voiceover] In the sequence above
the first term is one and each term
after the first is twice
the proceeding term.
What is the sum of the 16th, 17th,
and 18th terms in the sequence?
So let's write the sequence down again.
It's one, two, four, eight, 16,
and just keeps going on and on.
So the first term here,
this is the first term.
What is this?
Well one way to think about it is
that this is two to the zero power
and our second term right over here,
this is two to the first power.
And then our third term right over here,
this is two to the second power.
Our fourth term here, you see the pattern,
this is two to the third power.
Our fifth term in the sequence,
this is two to the fourth power.
So if we were to go to the 16th,
17th, and 18th terms, so let's go there.
So if we were to go to,
if we were to go to the, so dot, dot, dot,
if we were to go to the 16th, 17th
and 18th term, the 16th term is going
to be, if we just follow this pattern
right over here, it's going to be
two to the one minus less
than the term power, right?
When it's the fifth term,
it's the fourth power,
when it's the fourth term,
it's the third power.
So this is going to two to the 15th power.
This is going to be two to the 16th power
and this is going to be
two to the 17th power.
And so what's the sum of the 16th,
17th and 18th terms in the sequence?
Well it's going to be,
it's going to be two to the 15th,
plus two to the 16th,
plus two to the 17th.
Now this is accurate,
but if you were taking
this on a test and this wasn't the form
that they have it in, we could try
to manipulate this a little bit
and the one way to manipulate it would be
well let's try to factor
out a two to the 15th power.
So if you factor out a
two to the 15th power,
so this is going to two to the 15th times,
so two to the 15th divided
by two to the 15th,
that's just going to be one.
Two to the 16th divided
by two to the 15th,
well that's just going to be two, right?
Let me write that down.
Two to the 16th over two to the 15th,
that's equivalent to two
to the 16 minus 15th power,
which is just equal to two to the first,
which is just equal to two.
So that's going to be one plus two,
and then finally two to the 17th,
two to the 17th divided by two to the 15th
is equal to two to the second power,
or just four.
So just four right over there,
and there's, this obviously will simplify
to one plus two plus four is just seven,
is just seven.
So the answer to their question?
It would be seven times two to the 15th.
So it'd be seven times
two to the 15th power.